hey leute minecraft 1.3 ist soeben
erschienen ich hatte das glück und war
gerade auf twitter als coaching und chap
und alle möglichen leute von minecraft
das gepostet haben
minecraft 1.3 wird hier eingeblendet ist
es aber bisher nur eine pre release
version wenn ihr euch davon selbst
überzeugen wollt in der beschreibung
findet ihr einerseits den download link
vom server und einerseits im download
link wenn ihr das alleine testen wollt
also es gibt hier schon wie in den
vorherigen snapshots schon bekannt
geworden ein paar neue settings wie zum
beispiel die chat einstellungen dass man
hier die deckkraft und alles mögliche
anstellen kann wenn ihr auf einem server
seite das werde ich auf jeden fall
nutzen auf irgendwie 60 prozent stellen
oder so etwas also da ist das ganz
interessant dann gibt es hier überall
auch server texturen ganz viele
verschiedene neue möglichkeiten sprachen
sind wohl auch ein paar dazu gekommen
habe ich jetzt noch nicht so wirklich
neue gefunden aber sollen schon ein paar
neu dazu gekommen sein
außerdem wenn man nun hier auf die
snooker settings geht kann man hat man
viel mehr möglichkeiten die man
einstellen kann also viel mehr daten die
man dann wirklich verändern kann und man
sieht auch teilweise in welcher version
man gerade spielt exakt auf welchem
betriebssystem also wirklich so ein paar
mehr informationen über das spiel man
kann das natürlich auch alles ausmachen
wieder anstellen aber das ist egal so
wenn ihr euch nun eine neue welt
erstellt könnt ihr übrigens auch noch
hier die bonus truhe an und ausmachen
und die chips erlauben ich werde jetzt
einfach mal eine neue welt erstellen
also das waren jetzt erstmal so die
änderungen die ich im internet auf
deutsch gefunden habe es soll jetzt bin
ich hier neuen welt irgendwo hier genau
da ist jetzt diese bonus truhe ich laufe
da mal ganz kurz
dort findet ihr jetzt die ersten items
quasi die ihr sofort benutzen könnt dann
können wir natürlich die fackeln
mitnehmen die noch ein wenig partie sind
aber wie gesagt das ist nur ein privileg
version wir können ja auch sofort ich
mache das man ihn mit der axt können sie
die gäste mitnehmen dann haben wir quasi
schon sofort alle dinge die man braucht
um auch wirklich am anfang sofort nicht
sofort
runter gemetzel zu werden und so weiter
also das ist echt ganz interessant was
die sich jetzt alle einfallen lassen wir
oben schon sieht alles noch da alles wie
beim alten ich mag ja solche alten
welten da hatte depp gemeint dass die
auch öfters vorkommen werden solche
einfach solche welten die man früher in
minecraft hatte sage ich mal dass man
wirklich diese alten höhlensystem und
alles möglich so wie früher die alten
bäume finde ich ganz schön solche welten
dann auf englisch kann ich euch noch ein
paar sachen vorlesen wäre nicht einfach
mal so ein bisschen rumlaufen oder euch
hier mal die tolle landschweine zeige
wie game namens und internen server in
singleplayer modus also auch wenn ihr im
singleplayer seit läuft hier automatisch
immer einen server drüber des
singleplayer server can be shared und
lan also ihr könnt quasi euren server
ohne irgendwelche server zu erstellen
eure singleplayer weltoffene lan quasi
veröffentlichen das geht hier ganz
einfach im laden öffnen könnt ihr das
alles hier auswählen also
dann außerdem meldet possible to use
client zeit kommen es bei in nebligen
jazz das habe ich jetzt noch nicht ganz
so verstanden also ich packe website in
die beschreibung könnte dann einfach mal
selber euch von überzeugen rettet den
optional bonuses to get started quickly
also das war dieser kiste hier wo die
ganzen sachen drin waren possible truce
villagers edit amerells se currency also
smaragde sind jetzt quasi so die währung
und wenn ihr dann in welche villiger
sieht könnt ihr mit den anderen habe ich
auch früher schon mal vorgestellt in
einer früheren vorstellung von einer
version das video findet ihr irgendwo
auf einem kanal dann außerdem
jugend mit ort von avatar tasks denn des
monsters monsters also man kriegt nicht
nur erfahrungspunkte wenn man jetzt
monster zerstört sondern auch wenn man
keine ahnung in wie weizen anbaut oder
was weiß ich irgendwie so also nicht
dass man nur erfahrung wirklich gericht
wenn man monster zerstört
server scan automatischer just and
distribute texture pack also wenn ihr
auf einen server geht kann es sein dass
direktor texture pack geändert wird wenn
ich zum beispiel auf irgendeinem
survival serverseite wie zum beispiel
der isetta gibt's ja teilweise server
das dann wirklich alle die gleichen
voraussetzungen haben
edit new world map elements das
notariat dh wenn jetzt nur alte map habt
und ihr wollt unbedingt in diesem wüsten
dieser tollen pyramiden drin haben da
müsste wirklich einfach nur ein bisschen
rumlaufen büßten biom finden und in
euren alten webb wird das quasi auch
ergänzt werden edit kakaobohnen endet
die ändert es die ändert es ist halt die
können da nicht hinstellen und da und da
sind halt die gleichen sachen drin
beziehungsweise ihr könnt das quasi so
verbinden wie das internet quasi
tripwire habe ich auch schon mal
vorgestellt das sind quasi diese fäden
wenn man über die drüber läuft dann
funktioniert irgend so eine redstone
schaltung stufen und levers also
schalter können nur noch upside down
place werden also unter irgendwelchen
blöcken ist bestimmt ganz interessant
wenn man den innenraum ist und dann
denkt man sich wo ist der schalter ist
er wirklich über einem das ist bestimmt
ganz interessant für adventure maps et
cetera boden loks can be placed sideways
also wurden loks was genau damit gemeint
ist kann ich jetzt auch so doch ich
glaube dass in dieser halb platten die
kann man nun auch ich sag mal schräg
positionieren da hinten ist ein toller
berg da möchte ich jetzt unbedingt dahin
laufen
und wenn ihr noch weitere informationen
über die neue version sehen wollt in der
beschreibung sind die ganzen links von
unter anderem download
den zieht von dieser welt kann ich euch
auch mal die beschreibung packen weil
das liegt ja schon mal sehr ethnisch aus
da hinten also sieht es in der
beschreibung download ist dann
beschreiben die weiteren infos sind in
der beschreibung würde ich sagen
downloaded es euch und ihr könnt ja
vielleicht selber die änderungen
vorstellen und hier als video an
prozenten nicht nehmen sie auf jeden
fall an also ich erst jetzt mein
sandwich und dann sehen wir uns beim
nächsten mal